yeah one day my dad would grab my
brother's throat boom in the wall and I
would just watch him like what the f you
want to play basketball
H now my dad's in Korea no one day my
dad was just like hey son I'll be back
in a week and I was like okay Dad 10
years later he messages me what' he say
how are you
doing did you take care of Mom I'm like
that's your job 10 years were you just
guessing what happened yeah we were in
like elementary middle school and I was
like yo when's he coming back Mom want
to pierce my ears just never came back
he bounced on you and your mom and my
little brother that's when I saw my
whole
family crumble cuz my dad was the money
maker so my mom she would be working
6:00 a.m. to 6:00 a.m. wow that's why
you got a th000 jobs that's why I got
1,000 jobs we're just doing whatever we
want stealing food cuz we had to
stealing pens just for school but we
didn't even go
school but you want pant just in case